c'était démunis démunis démunis qui
jaillit mon mari nous éclate chez lourd
pour point claire pèlerins s'est occupé
de son mari malade jusqu'à la dernière
minute
la douleur au ventre elle a dû le placer
en chercher celle dés cet été
une résidence de soins de longue durée
elle est révoltée de constater le peu de
cas accordé aux aînés par les
gouvernements on a payé nos taxes on a
payé nos impôts
lyon ambitionner ou les a payés on les a
payées
je porte c'est pas une question de
retour mais c'est une question
d'équilibré est pas clair est venu
chercher du répit ici ou regroupement
des aidants naturels de la mauricie
située au cap de la madeleine
il regroupe 700 membres on y offre même
des cours pour aider les aidants comme
l'expliquent sa présidente
ceci leur croyance qu'on donne aux
formations de déplacements sécuritaires
les aidants ci serait pas l'eau à usage
agricole
les besoins en mauricie sont immenses
les aînés représentent 22 % de la
population une population qui est pauvre
depuis cinq ans on y amorcer un virage
important de soins à domicile
comme l'expliquent 7 geria s'adapter
parce qu'à 20 on marchait plus long non
c'est pas vrai on n'était pas autonomes
à la marche
50 kg il fallait lien fait chaud celles
des sociétés talent mais ce n'est pas
assez selon réjean hébert ancien
ministre de la santé qui prône les soins
à domicile depuis des lustres à
autonomie égale ça coûte entre 8 et 10
fois moins cher me donner des services à
la maison que de les donner un certain 5
2 il donne les pays scandinaves en
exemple danemark qui consacre 75 % de
son budget des soins à long terme à
domicile et seulement 25% en institution
s'est complètement les verts se noue
claire pèlerins souhaite de son côté
qu'elle ne connaîtra pas le même sort
que son mari ici catherine kovacs radio
canada trois rivières
oui